what if you were injured and developed
severe pain that wouldn't go away would
your government let you take the kind of
medication you need
I never thought directly about suicide
but I did at a couple of different
points in that thing it would be better
not to be alive
one day in 2005 Scot Gardner was cycling
to work along this path when a homeless
man pushed him off his bike Gardner's
body slammed into this jagged part of
the pavement that was viciously painful
I screamed in pain I think I passed out
a little bit this is the first time he's
returned to the scene of the accident
this is where my life changed and now
now it's really hitting more weigh more
than it did then Gardner's injuries
included a broken femur a broken
collarbone three crushed ribs
a concussion and a collapsed lung
there's a lot of things I just can't do
after eight surgeries and countless
hours of physical therapy Gardner's once
active life is now filled with
limitations I can't walk very far I'll
never run again he suffers from chronic
pain that prevents him from sleeping
more than a few hours at a time and yet
his pain today is nothing compared to
the agonizing days and months following
his accident when there's nothing but
pain there's no reason to live there
were times where the only way I could
stay sane and civil was because I could
take painkillers I could take the
vicodin when I needed it but what about
people who get injured today if there
was anything fortunate about Gardner's
accident it was that it happened long
before this recent news but now a Food
and Drug Administration panel is
sounding the alarms this panel is now
recommending that combination
prescription drugs that include
acetaminophen like percocet and vicodin
be pulled from the market some of the
most effective prescription medications
contain acetaminophen a popular
painkiller also found in many
over-the-counter drugs
the FDA panel says it's better to ban
drugs like vicodin and percocet than
risk the liver damage that is caused by
ingesting too much acetaminophen it's a
new twist on an old fear prescription
drug abuse are you or someone you know
at
to prescription pills we hear about
famous people end up addicted to
painkillers they once used for
legitimate medical conditions I took the
pain pills from a car accident for a leg
injury and PSA suggest that regular
people get addicted all the time and
then I tried to stop but it was just way
too addictive blood all over me from
shooting up and so you might be shocked
to hear gardeners say this I didn't
become addicted and it was very easy to
go off of them as long as I could could
you know do it in a controlled manner
surely he must be the exception that
proves the rule the fear that people
will become addicted in large numbers
for medical treatment is just hype is
propaganda dr. Frank Fisher is a Harvard
trained physician he says these people
are the exceptions when patients take
control substances particularly opioid
analgesics for chronic pain the
addiction rate is incredibly low in 2008
the Official Journal of the American
Academy of pain medicine published a
review of studies on the topic what did
the review find among patients who were
prescribed pain medication and had no
prior history of drug abuse the abuse or
addiction rate was less than one-fifth
of 1% the nation of zombies but that's
not the story we hear on TV woke up
three days later covered in my own feces
or in a blind panic about these supposed
threats and they're very small compared
to most other things that actually
threaten our society the FDA panel says
458 people die each year from
acetaminophen overdoses and that
justifies banning medication like
vicodin and percocet but nearly 700
people die from drowning and swimming
pools each year and more than 1,800 died
falling downstairs should we ban pools
and stairs all medications are dangerous
we got to remember that yes but
shouldn't we also remember that pain
patients need these medications I took
vicodin for a couple of years I don't
feel bad that I did it
I needed it it got me through a very
tough period in my life and this can be
said yankem off the market no more
vicodin no more percocet what if the
government does end up
any many prescription painkillers to me
this intensely cruel I don't think
people who haven't dealt with pain
really know what it's like remember
we're all just one accident away from
having to deal with severe chronic pain
so if that day ever comes here's hoping
you get the treatment you need for
reason TV i'm ted bala Kerr